and we will call this meeting of the Huntsville City Council to order. We are met in the chambers in Huntsville, Alabama.
We welcome all those who have joined us here in person and who are watching virtually and
we would like to extend a special welcome to Amy Wallace, who is our intern in the City Council
office. This is her first council meeting. We have enjoyed having her here and
we'll enjoy working with her this summer, so welcome Amy.
I also have been asked to make an announcement that a wallet and keys were left in the lobby
and if you are missing your wallet and keys, please check with the officer at the security desk. He's holding them for you.
So welcome again. As is our practice,
we will begin with an invocation offered by one of our Huntsville, Alabama Public Safety Chaplains. Tonight
we are joined by Chaplain Don Eady and
after the invocation we will have Mr. Little
Little lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance. So all who are willing and able, please stand for the invocation and Pledge of Allegiance.
Father, we're so grateful today for your gift of grace to us, the gift of life and strength, the ability to get up and get around.
How thankful we are for that. We pray for our fellow citizens who are not able to do that today,
not able to get up and get around. We pray your grace on them that you would bless them this evening.
Father, we pray for
patience and wisdom as we interact with one another and
Lord, I pray especially for discernment for the council as they wrestle with the issues that are before them on the agenda tonight and
Lord, we just want to please you and honor you as we love you and love one another. We pray in the name of Jesus. Amen.
To the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under God,
indivisible with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you, Chaplain Eady. Thank you, Councilmember Little.
And I failed to establish that we have all council members present and also Mayor Battle.
Council members, on the agenda, there are a couple of changes that we need to make you aware of.
The first is that item 7A has been deleted, presentation by the Huntsville Police Citizens Advisory Council.
We will look forward to hearing from them in July.
We are also deleting at the request of the sponsors item 20-0 and 20-X.
So please make that change on your agendas. Are there any other changes that need to be made to the agenda?
Seeing none, is there a motion to approve the agenda as it has presented?
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling. All in favor, please, any opposed?
Motion from Mr. Kling. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed? The motion or the agenda is approved with those changes.
Council members, you also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held on May 28, 2026 before you.
Are there any additions or changes to be made to those minutes?
Seeing none, the minutes will be stand approved.
We have no special recognitions from the Mayor.
The Council has one special recognition. 6A is a resolution recognizing the accomplishments of the University of Alabama in Huntsville's UAH eSports program.
The Chair moves for approval.
Second.
Second from Mr. Kling. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed? The motion carries.
I have the pleasure of presenting this resolution.
Yep.
Sports members, if you will please come.
This is a big team because it actually represents four teams, right?
So, I'll be down here with you.
Let me just share with you this resolution because some of you may not even know what eSports are.
Whereas the City Council and the Mayor of the City of Huntsville, Alabama, wish to recognize the outstanding accomplishments of the University of Alabama in Huntsville UAH eSports and its student athletes for their exceptional performances during the 2025-2026 competitive eSports season.
And whereas UAH eSports competed in the National eSports Collegiate Conference, NECC, one of the nation's premier collegiate eSports organizations and demonstrated remarkable success this season with nine of its 27 teams qualifying for the national tournament.
And whereas four UAH eSports teams advanced to the deepest stages of their respective national playoff brackets, showcasing the program's talent, dedication, and teamwork on a national stage.
And whereas UAH's Valorant Blue Team captured the NECC National Championship on May 4th following an already impressive season in which the team also secured a regional championship victory, further establishing itself among the nation's collegiate eSports teams.
And whereas UAH's Marvel Rivals Blue Team earned a place among the top competitors nationally, advancing to compete against California State University Sacramento for third place in the national tournament bracket after finishing fourth in the regional playoff competition.
Whereas UAH's Counter-Strike White Team advanced to compete for an NECC National Championship title after also earning a regional championship victory earlier in the year.
There's more.
Whereas UAH's League of Legends Blue Team also won a regional championship title in the 2025 season. And whereas within the UAH eSports program, Blue Teams represent varsity level competition and White Teams represent junior varsity level competition.
And the success achieved by both levels of teams reflects the continued growth and national prominence of eSports at the University of Alabama in Huntsville.
Now therefore, be it resolved that the City Council and the Mayor of the City of Huntsville, Alabama do hereby recognize and commend the accomplishments of UAH eSports and its student competitors and extend immense appreciation to the pride and distinction these teams have brought to the University and the Huntsville community during their commitment, sportsmanship and competitive excellence.
Join me in congratulating our UAH eSports teams.
And now let me turn this over to Efren Hummel who will tell us a little bit more about what this really represents.
Absolutely. Thank you so much for the beautiful words. We are very honored to be here in front of you all today and in front of all of the viewers watching as well.
UAH eSports or the eSports club at UAH is an absolute staple of the UAH campus. We're very glad to be able to do what we do.
Currently we have about 130 competitive members across our 27 teams. So it is one of the largest clubs on campus and we're very proud of that.
And we're very proud of these teams as well for excelling in their playoff divisions and committing the time as well required in order to practice and scrimmage and stay at the highest levels of competition.
These athletes that stand before you are the best of the best and we're very happy to be here. Down the line I will introduce a few of our different teams.
So Prem right here is one of the representatives from our League of Legends team. These two right here are new officers for the eSports program.
Here in the middle is our two representatives from Valorant. Marvel Rivals standing here third to the right and finally Counter-Strike at the very end.
I got the pleasure of coaching our Counter-Strike team as well. And I forgot to introduce myself. I'm sorry. My name is Ethan Hummel. I am the student director of eSports at UAH.
And so I've been very pleased to have this position to be able to lead at an advisory level for the club and direct what the new officers are able to do.
So thank you so much for this opportunity.
Well thank you for your service to these team members and I will also point out that my grandson Alex Austin was on the national championship Blue Valorant team.
So that's a special thing for us. So again join me in congratulating our eSports team.
Thank you.
We do a lot of important things at these meetings but I think nothing is as important as recognizing the good work that's being done by a lot of different people in our community.
We have no announcements and presentations. No matters with legal representatives and this brings us to public hearings to be held.
9A is a public hearing on a resolution authorizing the demolition of an unsafe building constituting a public nuisance located at 3804 Melody Road, Northeast Huntsville, Alabama and consideration of a resolution pertaining to the same. Mr. Irwin.
Yes, Councilmembers, Mayor Battle, Scott Irwin, Community Development Department. This is an appeal of community development findings related to the property on Melody Drive. The resolution, pardon me, the appeal of the community development findings and a public hearing on a resolution authorizing the demolition of the unsafe building constituting a public nuisance at 3804 Melody Drive.
The owners and entry parties were notified of the public hearing by certified mail and first class mail. The entry parties indicated they intended to appear before you to present any objections. We have photographs of the property for your review on the screen.
The property was initially inspected by an independent contractor who determined the structure was not structurally feasible for repair. It totaled out a 98 percent loss.
An official notice was sent by certified and first class mail requesting demolition and removal of the structure by April 22, 2026. No action was taken by the owners or entry parties, so we are here before you tonight requesting authorization to abate this public nuisance.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin. The public hearing is now open. I believe the property owners are here if you would like to approach the podium here. And if you will give us your name and address for the record, please.
Thank you so much. My name is LaRoy Barley, 9717 Rock Creek Road, Raleigh, North Carolina.
Thank you. Please proceed.
How are you doing? We are here, as Yafra mentioned, to really ask for consideration of more time in assessing the situation with this property. We have contacted and talked to several contractors who have looked at it externally, and because of the notice on it, et cetera, no one has gone in it to check.
We're one of the things we'd like to ask is to be able to proceed to go inside. We have stayed away from doing that because of the notice to not want to go in.
Other thing is travel. My sister and I think was mentioned that we live out of state quite a distance away. And just getting here can be difficult. We do have family who has kept a watch on it and things of that nature, make sure the property is stayed closed, which it has, et cetera.
So that is kind of where we are with that. One of the things that has, as the people we have discussed this with as far as contractors, no one has given us or counseled us in that it needs to be torn down.
Everyone has been very encouraging, saying, no, this can be saved. But they have wanted to go inside, and we just have not gone in because we didn't think we were permitted to at this time with the notice and what have you.
Myself and my older brother, we have gone in it in times prior to the notice being said that you could not. And it does look like, you know, being around these things before a property that could be saved, even though there is, we know it's great work that is needed and there will be a cost.
Post that or past that, once we determine what that cost would be, how extensive, we would like then to make a decision on how we proceed from there. We just don't think it is necessary to tear it down without an adequate assessment of what would be needed and get full numbers on that.
We just have not been able to conclude that currently because we have not been able to get inside the property. We have only been able to assess it from the outside with those that have been able to look at it this far.
Thank you, Mr. Barley. Is there anyone else who wishes to comment?
Anyone else wishing to comment? Then the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution?
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the chair.
Now discussion.
Yes.
Mr. Erwin.
Do you know if the house is safe for anyone to go inside and inspect it?
So when a property has been deemed unsafe, so you are not allowed to enter that property because it would be a danger of liability. So at this point, no, based on that fact, it is not suitable for someone to enter.
So it is not structurally sound?
Correct.
Okay. Has anyone from the family been in contact with you?
Yes, I spoke with the family back in April and explained the process that we would do to move forward on our position, which the property was beyond a renovation or rehabilitation type activity.
And based on the independent contractor assessment, which was a 98 percent loss, as staff, we deemed that it was appropriate for this property to be demolished.
So even with the notice not to enter, they couldn't enter with a different contractor and one of the community development member?
So yes, the contractor could, but not for individuals could not. It would have to be someone who has license able to evaluate whatever the necessary structural integrity aspects are being evaluated are.
Okay. So in the intervening time between when it's supposed to be demolished and today, if they could get a contractor in there before it's torn down and they decide that it is salvageable, what would happen?
Yeah, our position as staff that it still is beyond that. However, we could arrange for them to review that. We are still going forward and asking your authorization to abate the nuisance.
Okay. Thank you.
And what's your timeline on that?
So we normally take the minimum of 30 days being under public works schedule going forward. It is a busy time. It could go slightly more than that.
But everyone typically does have a minimum of 30 days before we are actually able to mobilize and move forward with any demolition.
Mr. Kling.
Question or just an idea to throw out on the table since the only time we really get to talk about these things is in this venue.
What if we were to give approval for Mr. Irwin to proceed as he sees fit, including demolition, time extension or whatever?
What we've done in the past, we basically give him the hammer and we trust his judgment if it looks like there's some light at the end of the tunnel.
But at the same time to counter that, to throw out, how would the people who live in that neighborhood feel about what I think is a pretty bad blight?
Do they want to have this extend longer or have we been hearing any complaints from people in that neighborhood?
So that's a double edged sword I'm throwing out.
So your proposal is to move forward with.
No, well actually I'm just kind of throwing out on the table both arguments to see if there's some consensus on the council as far as what to do.
Mr. Meredith, I believe you have a comment.
If the only way to do that is for you to put up a motion for an amendment and us to vote on that.
Well, that's what I was trying to ascertain.
So we have a motion right now on the floor to proceed with demolition.
As I understand that will not take place for 30 days and in that 30 days time period, if the Barlow family had a contractor, you would permit that contractor to go into the building to make an evaluation?
That's correct.
We would handle this as we do all of our public nuisance activities.
We would work with the owner for the most equitable way to get this property secured and removed if needed.
If there's an argument to be made by an independent contractor that it is ready and able to be renovated with a budget and a timeline, then we would certainly be willing to look at that.
Any other questions or comments?
So they have 30 days before it's going to be demolition, scheduled to be demolition.
So during that time frame, hopefully Mr. Barley can get with you and schedule a time for a contractor to come out and then that way we would know even if we vote if there's a possibility for the House to be redeemed.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
Thank you, Councilman.
Mr. Barley, we will let you meet with Mr. Irwin to work out how you can get that contractor to take a look.
Thank you for being with us tonight.
Safe travels back to Raleigh.
We have several public hearings to be set.
10A is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 2.41 acres of land lying on the west side of Old Big Cove Road and south of Worley Drive to residents to district and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for July 23, 2026?
Second.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
10B is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 2.47 acres of land lying on the south side of Old Highway 20 and east of Greenbrier Parkway to commercial industrial park district and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for July 23, 2026?
Motion to approve.
Second from Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries.
10C is a resolution to set a public hearing on the rezoning of 505.3 acres of land lying on north of Bob Wade Lane east and west of Mount Lebanon Road from residents to and residents to be districts to plan development housing district LUI 4556 and the introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for July 23, 2026?
Motion from Ms. Watkins, second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
The motion carries.
The hearing is set.
That concludes our public hearings and we have no agenda related comments.
So that brings us to comments from Mayor Battle.
Mayor Battle.
I'll pass on my comments tonight.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
We will now have comments from council members and we will begin with council member John Meredith.
I'll pass on mine as well.
And next we have council comments from council member Michelle Watkins.
Okay.
I have a couple of people I need to thank on Sunday.
As I was getting out of church, I received a phone call that Medeiros Road and Shepherd had flooded.
And I got on the phone with Shane Davis, Chris McNeese, and when I got to the scene, fire department was there and they were trying to get the drainage cleared out.
I want to thank the fire department, the House Police Department, Chris McNeese and Public Works for acting fast and getting the road cleared.
I really appreciate their attention to the details and to making sure that the residents were safe.
So thank you so much for that.
Trevor Lacy Basketball Camp will be on Saturday, June 20th from 9 to 12 at John Hunt Park.
There's a registration link on the city website.
If you are interested, ages 10 to 17, please register your children.
It's completely free.
There's no cost involved.
Health Fair in District 1 will be June 27th from 9 to 12 and it will be at the Johnson Legacy Center.
Another event that's free to the community.
You can come out, talk to some health care professionals and we would love to have you there.
Thank you so much.
Oh, one last thing.
I think the city lost yesterday, Team Redstone.
So either way, whoever won, I won at the same time.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins.
Mr. Kling.
Thank you, Madam President.
Ms. Watkins, behind which dugout were you sitting?
I was.
There you go.
Okay, you're fine.
She's Swiss.
Okay.
Madam President, I'd like to ask, is Mr. Davis here by chance?
Shane?
We all, and I'm right up there with everybody, we all love road resurfacing.
Everybody knows that.
That's the most exciting thing.
I just want to express a concern to Shane that maybe you could talk to the folks about.
There are several streets within the district that were part of the fiscal year 2025, phase three and four.
Those streets have not been resurfaced.
The concrete curbing and stuff have been put down.
But I noticed over the last couple of weeks, just walking around different neighborhoods,
a couple of these that are supposed to have been done, again, with FY25, Holiday, Eustis, Cypress, Randolph, Harwood, Ponceanna, Pansy, Town and Country,
which I think is being worked on today, and Hillmont and Fennell.
Most of those, but not all of those, are part of the FY25 contracts.
And it's been a little bit of a hardship for the residents because all the concrete is laid, things are kind of messy, and the asphalt person hadn't come.
And I just want to ask if you guys could check with, I guess, the contracts you got and see if there's a way we could accelerate the contract from that.
But again, not all of those, but most of those were FY25 contracts.
And you would expect those would be done before we even got into the FY26 contracts, which certainly I'm glad any way we can get any of those accelerated.
Yeah. So good evening, St. Davis Director, Urban Economic Development.
Councilman Kling, after the meeting, I'll get that list.
Okay.
Sometimes what will happen is that Public Works has to wait on streets to get cleared.
Hunts for Utilities is upgrading a gas line, water line, or the sewer department.
That could be the case.
But what I'll do is I'll get that list from you, I'll coordinate with Mr. McNeese at Public Works, and we'll get you an update in the morning.
I've been hearing from people, but have you explained to them that the money's already been appropriated, the contract?
That's right.
So it's not a question of if it's going to be done, it's when.
But certainly people are, shall we say, eager to have the...
As I would be, too.
Okay.
But we'll get with Mr. McNeese in the morning and get you an update, sir.
Okay. Thank you, sir.
You're welcome.
That's all, Madam President.
Thank you, Mr. Kling.
We'll now hear from Councilmember David Little.
Thank you, Madam President.
Just to be real quick and brief, I'd like to thank Public Works, the Police Department, Traffic, our Engineering and Inspections Departments for all being quick to respond to some citizen needs over the last few weeks.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Little.
I acknowledged Amy Wallace, our City Intern in our Council Department at the beginning of the meeting, but I want to extend a special welcome to all our interns.
All our departments have many interns here from many different schools, colleges, universities, and they are going to have a wonderful summer here, many of them.
In fact, in our office, we have hired two of our interns on our regular staff, so I know it will be a great experience for them and we look forward to having them continue to serve with the city.
I would like to remind everyone about the Independence Day celebration on June 27th that will be held at Ditto Landing.
It is sort of the kickoff for a week that will celebrate the 250th anniversary of the signing the Declaration of Independence.
So on June 27th, gates will open at Ditto Landing at 5 o'clock.
There is no admission charge, but to park it is $5 per car and cash only, so keep that in mind.
Festivities start at 6 o'clock with concerts, food trucks, and fireworks will be at 9 o'clock.
So please join us for the Independence Day celebration at Ditto Landing on June 27th.
Again, it is going to kick off that whole week of events which will culminate on July 4th parade downtown here in the city of Huntsville starting, I believe, at 5 o'clock that evening with fireworks to follow.
So lots of fun things planned for the 250th.
We'll go on now with the Finance Committee Report. Mr. Meredith, 14A is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment.
I move for authorization and approval of expenditures and the amount of $23,901,553.73.
Second from the chair. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed? The motion carries. Is there a report?
No report. Thank you.
We have no board appointments to be voted on. We do have several board appointment nominations.
16A is a nomination to appoint. These are nominations only. They will be considered at the June 25th meeting.
16A is a nomination to appoint Nano Tate to the Huntsville Electric Utility Board, a seat previously held by Kimberly Lewis for a three-year term to expire July 1, 2029.
16B is a nomination to reappoint Jim Batson to the Huntsville Natural Gas Utility Board to his current seat for a three-year term to expire July 1, 2029.
16C is a nomination to reappoint Jim Batson to the Huntsville Water Utility Board to his current seat for a three-year term to expire July 1, 2029.
16D is a nomination to reappoint David Mathis to the Huntsville Madison County Marine and Port Authority.
City Council Place 1 is current seat for a five-year term to expire July 1, 2031.
16E is a nomination to appoint Yolanda Sales to the Human Relations Commission.
Place 1 to fill vacancy due to the resignation of Remi Lispowden for the remainder of a vacant four-year term to expire September 8, 2026.
16F is a nomination to appoint Paulette Risher to the Huntsville Madison County Railroad Authority.
City Place 1 to the seat previously held by Jere Wilson for a five-year term to expire May 22, 2031.
16G is a nomination to appoint Rushi Singhal to the Early Works Museum Board.
Place 9 to the seat previously held by William Clark for the remainder of a three-year term to expire June 26, 2028.
Are there any nominations from the floor?
Yes, Madam President. I nominate Samuel T. Green II to the Huntsville Electric Utility Board for the seat previously held by Kimberly Lewis for a three-year term to expire July 1, 2029.
Thank you, Ms. Watkins. Are there any other nominations from the floor? Mr. Meredith.
Given Ms. Watkins' nomination to a competing seat, I'd like to withdraw my nomination of Mr. Daniel Tate.
So please let the record show that the nomination for Daniel Tate at 16A has been withdrawn. And Samuel Green has been nominated from the floor.
Are there any nominations from the floor? Hearing none, we'll move on. We have no Huntsville Utility items.
We have a couple of legal items, transactions. So this is 18. 18A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of a utility under energy easement between the Tracts 1 and 2 Martinson Ranch.
Phase 4, is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the Chair. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed? The motion carries.
18B is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of a five-foot utility and drainage easement in Lot 2, Montesanto Construction Company, subdivision 1617, Montesanto Boulevard.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the Chair. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed? The motion carries.
We have no vacation of rights of way or deeds of acceptance. So that brings us to 19, unfinished business items for action. 19A is an ordinance to amend Chapter 15, license and taxes.
Article 3, sales, use, rental and lodging tax, division 5, lodging tax. Section 15 of the Code of Ordinances for the City of Huntsville regarding license fees.
Is there a motion from Mr. Little? Is there a second?
Second.
Second from Mr. Kling. I have been made aware that the administration has asked to postpone this item to the June 25th, 2026 meeting.
Is there a motion? The Chair makes the motion to postpone the June 25th meeting.
Second.
Second from Mr. Little. Any discussion?
All in. Motion from Mr. Little.
Motion to postpone. Motion to postpone the June 25th meeting from Mr. Little. Second from Mr. Kling. Is there any discussion?
All in favor to vote in favor.
There is discussion. Sorry.
I'm sorry. Mr. Meriden.
Could someone from the. Thank you, Mr. Hamilton. Explain why this is necessary.
Council Member, the item before you is a proposal to increase the lodging tax by 1% with that new 1% earmarked for capital improvements at the VBC.
As you're well aware, we're also in the process of bringing to you a TIF that would also be part of the funding strategy for that project as well as some others.
It's our recommendation that since both of those items are aligned to the same project and the TIF vote right now is scheduled to come to you at June 25th, our recommendation is better for you to handle both those things on the same night since they're tied to the same project and not have one get ahead of the other.
Thank you, sir.
Any other questions? Mr. Mayor Battle.
This is just part of our obligation to the Hotel Motel Association and all those who have supported this this effort to make sure that we follow through with our word what we gave them our word we do.
And also, one of the things that we try to do with any any, you know, fee structure or tax thing like this, but you know, particularly for lodging taxes, they have to do some things to be prepared to begin collecting it.
And so, you know, if with your passage at when it comes back, it would not actually take effect until October so that would give them sufficient time to update their system be prepared to begin collecting it in October.
Any other comments. All in favor please indicate.
Opposed motion carries, and the item has been postponed to June 25th.
19 B is an ordinance annexing 24.67 acres of land lying on the north side of University Drive east of Providence Maine is their motion to approve motion for Mr little second by the chair, Mr Nunez council members Thomas Nunez manager of plan and zoning services decided
was located north side of University Drive and east of Providence Main Street petitioners seeking to annex for city services.
Questions for Mr Nunez, Mr Meredith.
Do we have an idea of what's going to. Yes, this is for commercial retail development.
But we don't know of what nature. That's currently not have not been disclosed, but we are certain and it is will be proposed to be zone C for for commercial retail and possibly even some lodging components.
Okay, so smaller retail, or large yes, it could be 24 acres that gives us a fair amount of flexibility or the development team a fair amount of flexibility and how the scale of the development so depending on the marketing strategies in infused in.
They have some some options to put primarily commercial retail.
Then we don't apartments are viable under this zoning well this is not the zoning component that will come in a later date but if the proposal will be for see for, and if the council were to approve such then yes that would be a use that would be permitted.
Okay. Thank you, sir. You're very welcome.
Any other comments or questions, all in favor please indicate I pose motion carries 19 C is ordinance annexing 1.98 acres of land lying on the north side of capture road with.
Capture road west of Walter and a highway motion motion from Mr little second from the chair.
Mr Nunez, again this item is located north side of capture road and what's the water and the highway petition seeking the n h1.98 acres for also a commercial retail develop, but on a smaller scale.
Any discussion.
All in favor please indicate any eyes motion cares.
19 D is an ordinance to declare certain property surplus no longer needed for municipal use motion for Mr little second from the chair.
Any discussion.
Okay, Miss Watkins.
So, as I'm reading this is saying that it has to be destroyed to prevent a data breach, and the cost probably dispose of this is $3 per camera, but is the film backed up.
It is so the way to basically the basis of this is we have replaced old body worn cameras with a new system. What, what the IT professionals have figured out is the cameras themselves have some local storage in the device and so there's potential for data that could be a privacy issue for citizens or whoever.
So the way our systems work though is officers come in at the end of their shift and they download all that data, and then we have retention standards that are set for for all that data so this is just making sure that these cameras don't fall into somebody's hands who might try and you know, use it to file it so much privacy.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions.
All in favor please indicate, I impose the motion carries.
This brings us to 20 new business items for consideration or action these items will be approved in one motion unless any council member wishes to remove an item for discussion the reading each item will be waived less a council member requests otherwise.
Are there any items any council member wishes to hold for separate consideration.
Yes ma'am.
A, C, D, F, G, I, K, P, V, A, B.
Are there any other items anyone wishes to hold for separate consideration.
It went pretty quick. So I may be repeating some, would you like me to. So we have a C, D, F, G, I, J, K, and J, J was one that I asked to help.
I, J, K, P, V, and A, B.
Okay, yes ma'am. I would like to hold item K.
K is held. Yes sir.
And item N as in nano.
Got it.
We have item A, C, D, F, G, I, J, K, N, P, V, A, B.
And N yes.
Let me just get all of those down here.
Do we have P. Yes.
Okay.
And also please remember that item 20 O and 20 X have been deleted. So the chair moves for approval and consolidation of I consolidation and approval of items 20 B, 20 E, 20 H, 20 L, 20 M, 20 O, 20 Q to you, 20 W to double A.
Is there a motion to second for Mr. Little? All in favor please indicate.
Opposed? Motion carries. We'll move on now to 20 A. 20 A is a resolution authorizing travel expenses.
The chair moves for approval. Is there a second? Second.
Second by Mr. Little. Ms. Watkins, you held this. Your questions please.
Yes. Can you tell me from the last council meeting, I think it was, I want to say 14 or 15,000 last council meeting. So two weeks ago and now we're approving for 30,000.
Excuse me.
Yes, the amount actually this time. So the total cost of travel for this period was was $30,291.76. The employee reimbursement amounted to $8,355.93.
Too much detail. But basically it all depends on who travels to where, how large is the actual travel expense. So for this one, if my memory serves, I don't have the other one directly in front of me, was that there were fewer people that traveled in that time period.
And it may have even been for conferences that were like within the state as opposed to outside of the stage or something like this. For this particular one, we had, we had a number of places.
You know, there was a planning conference in Detroit, Michigan. There was the Decatur, Georgia, and there was some out of state ones that went to different places. So it all depends on kind of what's in state out of state and how many people actually travel in that time period.
So just to make sure that I'm tracking out of the 30,000, 8500 of the 30,000 was employee reimbursements.
Yes, ma'am. Okay. Thank you. Any other questions? I have a question. What is, I know there are times when multiple people from a department will need to go to the same conference.
Is there any limit to the number of people within a department that can travel to the same conference?
No, it all depends on kind of the requirements at the conference. You know, for instance, there may be CLE or CP or for us, CPE requirements, you know, continuing certification requirements for different registrations that we hold or different certificates that are held within the city by different employees.
Or or for just general, I know that for like the our national conference, we like a couple of people to try and go to that just in order to cover it. There's so many things happening at one time.
So so it just depends on conference to conference. And it is up to the department head as to how many people attend that conference.
Is there any ban or prohibiting factor for a whole department to accompany or to attend the same conference?
Not that I'm aware of. I'm not aware that that has happened. But but that may be maybe that's something that's occurred.
I it came to my attention that it has occurred, but certainly not within this bunch. I found it particularly odd that a whole department would take off for a week to attend the same conference.
But but if there are CLEs and other things involved, it makes more sense now.
But I appreciate you pointing that out. So thank you. Any other comments? All in favor, please indicate.
I'm opposed. Motion carries. Twenty C is a resolution authorize mayor to enter into an agreement to mutually terminate the janitorial services administrative facilities awarded to Office Pride Inc.
Pursuant to resolution number 26 dash four one three. Is there a motion to approve motion? Mr. Little second from the chair.
Mr. Hamilton, could you please share with us what we're doing here? Sure.
Council members will you'll note that that C and D are related to each other, but we need to handle them in sequence.
So we need to first focus specifically on C and then come to D in order. So janitorial services throughout city facilities is mostly handled by contract.
We do have a few employees that provide some janitorial service primarily here in City Hall.
But the vast majority of facilities are maintained by contract. We actually have two separate janitorial contracts.
One does administrative buildings and the other does all the parks and rec.
So what's the ones before you tonight is the one that focuses specifically on administrative buildings.
The parks and rec contract actually will come up in about six months for bids. So that that one is not part of its nice discussion.
So this is purely about the administrative buildings. This RFP went out several weeks ago.
It was evaluated and we had what was the low bidder.
Although this is one that was not determined purely based on low bid. It's actually a kind of a best value evaluation process.
But in this particular case, the contractor that was evaluated the highest was also the low bidder.
Unfortunately, after that contract was approved and what they have to do is once you approve the contract, they didn't have several things they have to do to be fully compliant, including getting a performance bond.
In this particular case, unfortunately, the contractor was unable to achieve some of those requirements.
And so that's why this cancellation is before you because they are not able to perform under this contract.
So we first need to cancel this contract. As I said, indeed, we will then take up the next action to deal with the repercussions that what's before you right this minute is specifically cancellation of this contract because of their inability to perform.
Questions for Mr. Hamilton.
Discussion. All in favor, please indicate I oppose the motion carries.
Twenty days.
Madam Chair, excuse me one second.
I mean, we need all of the members to speak into their microphone when you're voting.
Thank you.
Twenty D is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into agreement to award the janitorial services administration building contract previously awarded pursuant to resolution number 26 dash four one three to PJ H cleaning ink doing businesses Alabama cleaning services their motion to approve to approve Mr.
Little second from the chair, Mr. Hamilton.
So this is follow up to see it is so with the action that you just took.
So we no longer have a contract for for those facilities. And so this is how we deal with that.
So the contract before you is with PJ H cleaning doing businesses Alabama cleaning service.
They came in second in in the competitive process. I will tell you it was very, very close. I've actually seen the scoring rubric from from the committee.
It is in terms of the pricing, which obviously we particularly focus on pricing is for a full year about seventy thousand dollars more than than who was the low bidder.
But they performed very well and all the other metrics. And so our recommendation is that we now move to the second bitter, which is the one before you in order to approve this contract and allow them, excuse me, to to move forward.
Questions.
So just just to be clear, this contract then is from a bidder who was able to meet all the requirements.
Now they have the same issue. They there are certain things like going to get a performance bond and some other things you can't do until you actually have a contract.
So that's why, unfortunately, occasionally we bring you a cancellation where something has happened early in the process.
And so with your with your approval tonight, they will have an executed contract and that will allow them to go move forward.
Some of those final administrative things should they run into problems that will then we'll deal with that.
But but they can't take any of those steps until they actually have a contract.
Any other comments, questions? All in favor, please indicate.
I think I.
Any opposed? Motion carries.
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
Twenty F is a resolution from the authorized the mayor to submit an application to the Alabama Department of Economic and Community Affairs, a DECA for fiscal year.
Twenty twenty six emergency grant ESG funds to a motion for Mr.
Little there a second second by the chair, Mr.
Erwin. Yes, council members, Sutter when Community Development Department this time is the authorizing marriage,
submit an application to the Alabama Department of Economic and Community Affairs for ESG funding, which is emergency solution grant funding.
This is a pass through grant that we provide resources to our homeless service providers within the community to address homelessness.
The process is that we submit this application.
We then receive applications from our local service providers.
And then once we have the organization selected and their activity selected, they will come back to you with individual contracts with those organizations.
But they will address things such as street outreach, emergency shelters, homeless prevention and rapid rehousing.
Our expected application for this particular grant is five hundred thousand dollars.
Questions for Mr. Erwin.
OK, five hundred thousand.
Because on the notes, it's five million.
It was a typo. It's a typo.
OK, I just want to clarify, make sure.
Well, it's it's yeah.
Thank you. Thank you, Mr.
Other questions.
All in favor, please indicate by saying aye.
Aye. Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Twenty G is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into a contract between the city of Huntsville and low bidder Rogers Group Inc. for Ditto Landing Event Space parking lot based bid and option number one.
Project number seventy one dash twenty six dash SP thirty six. Chair moves for approval.
Second. Second from Mr. Little.
Mr. Davis. Thank you, Madam President. Good evening, Councilman Shane Davis, director of urban economic development.
So this is a project that's been in the capital plan for a couple of years from a budget standpoint.
We're now ready to bring the four city councils.
This is a partnership with Madison County as they're making a significant investment along the river for for Ditto with an event center, new leasing opportunities for Ditto to have new revenue coming in.
This council agreed a couple of years ago to provide the parking.
So the bid amount came in actually under budget.
The total contract amounts two million three hundred fifteen thousand dollars will provide 450 spaces to the Ditto Landing Event Area.
Also includes about 450 feet of greenway lighting and then land some new landscaping berms along Hobbs Island Road area.
Again, our budget was about three million dollars.
So this is under budget.
I would just make one comment that this is the entire project, which has been led by Commissioner Phil Riddick to do the event center and the restaurant space at Ditto is very exciting.
And we can't have any events if we don't have parking.
So this is a critical piece to make it work.
In addition to this, we've also done some sewer work as well, haven't we?
Yeah. So water pollution control actually self-performed that bringing sewer down to this area of Ditto Landing.
So we did that about a year ago.
So this this our infrastructure contribution is making this possible.
So thank you for the work we're doing on that.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate by saying aye.
Aye. Any opposed?
The motion carries.
Twenty I is a resolution authorizing mayor to enter into an agreement between the city of Huntsville and Shoal Engineering Company for engineering design services for roadway improvements along northern bypass and Memorial Parkway Project number 71 dash 26 dash Rd zero three and out of that project number CRSA STP HVP 10.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second from the chair.
Any comments or questions for Mr. Davis?
Mr. Davis, will you please explain what what this is exactly ought to be?
Yes, ma'am. Shane Davis, director of economic.
So council members, as you're well aware, we are getting close to wrapping up later this year.
The northern bypass extension will essentially go from Pulaski Pike to about 1500 feet east side of the parkway along the new food city in the middle of this construction project.
We've have secured a really major retail development currently anchored by Home Depot and Target and some others that we're working on.
So what this is doing is designing we've been working with out on access management for this new retail development, which would include two signalized intersections, one on the northern bypass one.
Memorial Parkway.
And then some right in right outs to some of the out parcels. So this would be a design contract to design that so we can utilize getting this in place before we finish the normal bypass.
We want to get these improvements, one to support this retail. If you've been up in that area, dirt is moving later this summer.
You'll start seeing footing and foundations go in for the first part of the retail, which will be Target and some other other junior boxes.
We're getting really close to announce. And then as we get into really late fall, you'll start to see the Home Depot start to come out of the ground.
So what we're trying to do is not open a brand new road and then have a bunch of orange barrels out there trying to get two signals in.
So we're really trying to let all this finish about the same time.
Any other comments or questions? All in favor, please indicate by saying aye. Any opposed? Motion carries.
Twenty Jays resolution off time mayor to enter into an agreement between the city of Huntsland Skipper Consulting Inc. for professional engineering services for an interchange access request IAR study along I-65 between exit 340 and exit 347 project number 71-26-SP47.
Move to approve. Motion from Mr. Little, second by the chair.
Mr. Davis, I held this because I think it would be interesting to the public to hear why we feel we need this additional access at this point.
Sure. Absolutely happy to explain. So I think this is an example of us trying to stay ahead of our transportation infrastructure.
This is certainly not our infrastructure, right? It's interstate 65.
But we all know we all use Huntsville, Limestone County, Decatur, Athens, all of us from a regional MPO.
The interchange of I-65 and 565 is very congested.
Expanding that interchange will cost a lot of money. It's not something that Aldot or Federal Highway is ignoring.
But we've been having conversations for about a year with Federal Highway Administration of saying a cheaper alternative from a three to four hundred million dollar interchange improvement project could possibly be looking between the Huntsville-Browns Ferry exit and I-565,
a new interchange that could be in the 30 million dollar range or 40 million dollar range that would provide connection into the growth corridor that we're seeing at Mazda, Toyota and the different things that are out in that western corridor.
Mark Bartley, Federal Highway said, we think that's a great idea. We said, well, can we help lead to kick this off? And he said, yes. So that's what this will do.
As we get into this, we will bring more to the public and certainly with Federal Highway, will the City of Huntsville build the interchange? Most likely not. But we want to accelerate. We want to advance and not wait until functional failure.
So I think this is a good example of us trying to be proactive as we did with Restore our Roads and some other partnerships we've had with Aldot in the past.
Mr. Meredith.
I don't have any questions, but I know we've been working on this interchange for quite a while. So I think it's wonderful to see the progress being made.
Yeah, so as Councilmember Mayer said, we did a light corridor study to kind of pigeon where the best location could be. Worked with Federal Highway on a couple of different locations.
What this will do is finalize that location, do some geometric of how that interchange would most likely connect over at some point to Moore'sville Road, Greenbrier Parkway, to the west side of 65, to Highway 31, which would provide access to Calhoun College, Prior Field.
So this will finalize where that future interchange would be, get approval from Aldot and Federal Highway so it's locked into their system.
Sounds good. Thank you very much, sir.
Any other comments?
All in favor, please indicate by saying aye.
Aye.
Any opposed? Motion carries.
20K is a resolution to authorize the Mayor to enter into a land lease agreement renewal between the City of Huntsville and Roger Martin Farms for the rent and lease of approximately 111 acres of unimproved land generally located in Cummings Research Park.
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second from Mr. Kling. Thank you.
Mr. Davis.
Yes, ma'am. So this is just what it says, it's a farm lease renewal. This is actually located in Cummings Research Park, so we have a number of these that come through here annually.
They vary in lease amounts, and I want for the public and for this Council to get you to understand or better understand why they're not the same price per acre.
So we work with a farmer that has interest in it, and then, you know, soil conditions, the amount of acreage, the location, what it takes to go plant a crop, get it harvested, get it out, and then is it irrigated or not.
So the other one you've held, you will notice that we're going to get to the lease amounts a lot more.
We actually have irrigation on it, so it produces a much greater yield such that, you know, they can pay more for the lease. So the lease amount in this is $8,400.
It is unirrigated in Research Park. What we mainly do here in Alabama, you let a piece of property sit dormant for a year, volunteer trees come up, we would spend a lot of money trying to maintain this.
So getting any revenue, just somebody maintaining it for us is actually saving the taxpayer money.
Thank you. Questions? All in favor, please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries.
20N as a resolution I'll thrive the mayor to enter into a land lease agreement renewal between the City of Huntsville and Devaney Brothers Farms for the rent and lease of approximately 131 acres of unimproved land lying in the vicinity of the Western Area Treatment Plant.
Motion for Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling.
So the same for this one, and let me find it on here. So this is 131 acres. I apologize. I was looking at the Devaney one that was like Greenbrier.
All I was going to ask is, why are the values on these properties so low? And I will, why are the values so low? Why is the city only getting $5,180 for letting a farmer?
Yeah, so for instance, this one is adjacent to the Western Area Wastewater Treatment Facility. So the site was actually a former laydown area for the construction of the treatment plant. So it's not fully topsoil. It's got some rock and some cherts. So it does produce a crop.
But if you go see it once it's planted, I've been down there, it's very sporadic. So it doesn't have a lot of land value, but we don't want it to grow up in privet and volunteer trees.
What I want to point out, since we're talking value, the Devaney farm one that was just the one I thought you were holding, I just circled the wrong one, is 233 acres at the Greenbrier exit. It's the remnant tract from the Eli Lilly that we'll retain.
It is irrigated and it's at $29,150 for about 100 acres. So much, much higher, but it's producing a yield. It's got great topsoil. It produces a good yield. So they're paying based off yield.
And frankly, even that is a cheap price. I was amazed at how little farmers pay on land leases. And I didn't want the public to think, well Huntsville has just given this stuff away. It is relatively inexpensive.
Kelly Davis in the engineering office handles these. And about every three years she'll call some of the large landowners that are doing that, Tate Farms and some of the others, and say, okay, kind of what is the lease rate that you're paying others? And then we try to adjust these based on that.
Thank you, sir. You're welcome, sir.
And we also, as they maintain this land for us, it also means that if we need it for something, we can quickly turn around. We don't have to do a lot of clearing.
Well, and the other thing is, take research work. That land's for sale. The land out at Greenbrier that you approved, it is marketable to go bring jobs. So at a moment's notice we may have a company that wants to come see that. It needs to show well.
It needs to see where you can envision this is a good piece of property. These farm leases have it in a condition that it's always well maintained and always shows well.
Any other questions? All in favor, please indicate by saying aye. Aye. Aye. Opposed? Motion carried.
20P is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into a design services agreement between the City of Huntsville and MPS Architecture PC for the Transit Station Office renovation. Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve. Motion for Mr. Klang, seconded from Mr. Little. Mr. Hamilton.
Councilmember Ruegel, before you is a design contract to convert some space in the Transit Center to office space. It's a relatively new facility, but we're also actively growing that system.
And so as Ms. Bryant's needing to kind of add some staff and change the way she's operating, we need a little bit more office space inside that facility. So this will convert some lobby space that's been lightly used into office space.
Thank you. Questions?
Is this at the new Transit Center? It is. So it's an addition to what's there?
It will not be an addition to the building. It's converting some interior space into office space. Oh, gotcha. Okay.
Other questions? Is there any reason to indicate that because this is taking place that there's going to be further transit route expansion in the future?
Well, there is plan. I mean, this change won't automatically turn into more buses, but you've seen some of the plans over the next few years to add more routes, add more hours, those kinds of things. And so that's continued to move forward.
This allows Ms. Bryant to properly staff it and deal with some of that increase of traffic into the facility. Thank you.
Any other questions? All in favor, please indicate by sign. Aye. Any opposed? Motion carries.
20V is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter into facility use agreement between the State of Honsoul and James Sec LLC for the event Le Dîner en Blanc Decatur.
I move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the chair. I'm not sure who held this. Question specific to this, Ms. Watkins?
Yes, exactly. What does this consist of with them? Because the event is in Decatur.
Well, it's not. It's actually in Big Spring Park. Oh, they have it in Big Spring Park this year?
They are, exactly. Oh, I didn't know that.
So I think that, yes, it's a little bit confusing where they have it. They left Decatur in their name, even though this particular event is in Big Spring Park.
So this is a standard facility use agreement that entities can get for park use.
This one, and sometimes others have to come before you because they will have alcohol involved and they have to get a special event permit from the State.
The State requires them to have a Council approved agreement for use of the facility.
So that's why it's before you versus a typical one Mr. Gossett has the authority to approve on his own.
That's all I need to know. Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
Any other questions or comments? All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed? The motion carries.
And 20 AB is a resolution authorizing acceptance of a corrective deed, correcting the legal description contained in the original deed recorded in Deed Book 2023, page 15-18 of the Proven records of Huntsville, Alabama, authorizing the mayor to execute a quick claim deed to convey the portion of land erroneously included in the original deed back to the parties.
Chair makes a motion. Second. Second from Mr. Little.
That's a whole lot of language there to help us understand very simply what we're doing.
Yes, ma'am. Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So the total reconveyance back to the landowners is only 1.15 acres.
It's actually in three really small locations.
So through the Hayes Farm development, they donated a lot of land for public space and public parks and greenways and trails.
And and is a really if you looked at the legal description of all that, it was about 22 pages.
So as we went back into that and then and started comparing with actually tax assessor of land, there was a couple of survey errors in just some minor turns of East Bay bearing or West Bay bearings.
We've got all that corrected and realized that there were some little pieces here and there that wasn't meant to be donated. It was meant to be retained. And we're just cleaning that up.
So just making sure that everybody's legal boundaries close and touch each other. So thank you. Just a minor survey and clean up.
Any questions? All in favor, please indicate. I say aye. Any opposed? Motion carries.
That concludes our new business items and we will now move to items for introduction.
These items are for introduction only. They will be considered at the June 25th meeting.
Twenty one a is the introduction of an ordinance amending Chapter eight businesses of the Code of Ordinances of the city of Huntsville to add Article six concerning private park and pay facilities.
Twenty one B is the introduction of an ordinance declaring certain equipment surplus and to be recycled for monetary value.
Twenty one C is the introduction of an ordinance to amend ordinance number 25 dash one nine four Chapter two administration.
Article 13 control of access to city owned controlled and lease premises of the Code of Ordinances of the city of Huntsville.
That concludes all of our business. And that brings us now to second roster public comments.
We have four people who have signed up.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on matters relating to city business, whether or not such items are on the agenda.
You met anyone who has signed up may speak.
And when called, approach the microphone, state your name, address and city residents for the record.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers will refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff and from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual.
So when I call your name, please come to this central podium here.
And I will also call the name of the person to follow so you can be ready to come.
The first person to sign up is Tonya Hawkins. Subject is safety measures at railroad tracks.
Miss Hawkins, he'll come forward who will be followed by Andre Austin.
Hi, my name is Johnny Hawkins and my address is 1538 Moon Town Road, Brownsboro.
Thank you. Yes. Good evening, everyone.
Back in 2004, I actually lived on Salty Bottom Road with my family, my mom and my father, and he was hit by a train at that crossing, unprotected, unmarked crossing at Salty Bottom.
After massive injuries that he incurred, he did survive, but survival is not the same as returning to the life he once had.
After that day, his world became smaller, his strength, his independence and the years that should have been spent spooling his grandchildren were all limited by what happened in those few terrifying seconds.
Our family has lived with that ever since.
Then more recently, tragedy struck again. Last month, Keegan and McKinley Davis lost their lives at that same railroad tracks at Salty Bottom Road.
Their family is here with us today. His father and his daughter.
That actually was in the accident with them and survived.
Lots of other supporters, if y'all would like to stand up just to show them who's here would be great.
The two lives that day was a 36 year old father and eight year old little girl gone in a moment that should have never been left so unprotected.
Two families changed forever at a crossing that gave no warning, no barrier, no second chance.
These are not isolated stories. They're reminders. A train can't swerve, it can't stop quickly.
And when a crossing has no lights, no gates, no protective barriers at all, the responsibility falls entirely on human judgment and the conditions are often hard to judge.
This is why safety upgrades matter. Lights, bells, crossing arms are not luxuries. They're life saving barriers between everyday travel and irreversible loss.
Every crossing like Salty Bottom Road, a crossing that has more than 2,100 vehicles that cross it every single day, a crossing that's had multiple fatalities, a crossing that remains unprotected is a risk sitting in plain sight.
City Council members, I respectfully ask for your help along with all of these people and several that couldn't come because they couldn't get off work.
In addressing the ongoing safety concerns at this railroad crossing at Salty Bottom, please work with ALDOT to make the necessary improvements before another tragedy occurs.
If funding is the primary obstacle, I know there are some that have said they are willing to contribute toward the local matching funds that the county was previously unable or unwilling to provide.
Our community continues to endure the devastating consequences of this dangerous crossing.
Families are grieving, lives have been forever changed, and the residents live with the fear that another preventable accident could happen anytime.
We urge you to take action and help protect the citizens of our community from further loss.
My father's life was altered in 2004. Keegan and McKinley Davis' lives were ended. We can't undo what's already happened.
Sorry, Ms. Hawkins.
We please ask for protection.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time and consideration.
We are very sorry for your loss.
The next person to speak is Andre Austin who will be followed by David Snyder.
Andre Austin, Kenyantlou, yes, Bain Drogh.
City of Huntsville.
City of Huntsville, yes.
And unfortunately there's no dialogue back and forth because my question is about community development.
And regarding community development, I was wondering if there is a code of conduct, an SOP, or standard operating procedures, in which bylaws there are for the community development personnel.
There is a situation, so I can't go back and forth with the actual personnel of community development.
There is a situation where a realtor calls community development. They don't even live here.
All right. That's a problem.
So a realtor calls community development, come out to my property, and you know, it's fine.
I'm still building a fence. You know, times are tough. You know, stuff happens. All right.
Why is it a realtor that don't even live in the community, don't even live in the neighborhood, is willing to make my life difficult?
Because I got to, obviously I'm coming out of pocket. I don't want to, you know, not be seen, you know, not be done myself.
You know, you know, it's a little frustrating because these folks, they call, they sell up the properties. They don't care about nobody live there.
And you got this personnel from the community development walk on the property that's for sale to look over into my over into my property, over the line, over the fence, whatever, trying to see what they can.
I don't know, violate, say this from jump back there with it.
Well, you can't see it from the road. It's construction screen up. So why are you going all the way back past the cartilage? That's the legal bound.
As far as I'm concerned, I'm sure any law enforcement can tell you they can't go past the cartilage unless it's in a similar in a similar circumstance.
So why is it that the community development personnel can walk all the way past the fence of the neighbor?
They say on tape that the neighbor and I recorded it said that the neighbor or the realtor, sorry, the realtor gave them authorization to walk past the fence to walk.
All in my yard where people are normal. You can't even see it on Google Maps. So why is it OK for him to see that?
I mean, intimate details talking about what license plate numbers, you know, and I'm telling what else he out there back there doing. Scott in the place. I try to figure out what you can steal.
I don't know these folks. And I think that is just disingenuous and disrespectful to have people from community development that they can just do whatever they want.
They more important than the police officers, I guess, and the fire department and the paramedics, people saving lives. They're not that important.
That's all I got to say. Thank you, sir. Mr. Irwin, would you like to have a conversation with Mr. Austin, Mr. Austin, Scott Irwin, our director of community development will meet with you out in the hall.
We will now hear from David Snyder and Mr. And David will be followed by Jerry Cox. Hello, my name is mixed David Snyder.
My information is written correctly on the sheet. I live in Huntsville, but a lot of my place. So this will go a little fast.
First, I would like to invite City Council and anyone in the audience and anyone listening to a screening of the Alabama Solutions documentary.
It'll be on June the 20th at the Fellowship Presbyterian Church on Meridian Street. I'm volunteering with United Women of Color. Come and check it out.
I would also like to just raise community awareness around a meeting that was had with our city council president, Ms. Robinson, Councilwoman Robinson and a few other representatives.
The police chief about flock and the camera system that we are in contract with as a city.
Caden Helbling submitted a FOIA request. It's an open records act request. And it was denied on the grounds that it was that the material was about investigations material, which was not true.
That is not factually true. And I think that is how a lawyer would phrase it is cadence arguing against the facts of the case.
That is not what the material was asked for pertains to.
I would like to mention during that meeting at a certain point, actually, someone in the room interrupted Councilwoman Robinson and just started talking right over Councilwoman Councilwoman Robinson.
And it just it rubbed me wrong. I wish that I had spoken up in that meeting when that happened and brought it up. I you know, I personally feel like I should have done better for that.
I was interested in what Robinson had to say about that. But we are awaiting a review. One thing that was agreed upon in that meeting is that by the 30th, a review of the denial and possibly a reevaluation and possibly a reversal will come through.
So we're anxiously awaiting that. There's also a default week of action starting August the 16th. Right.
I also want to bring a little community awareness about the battery, the meeting that happened about the battery that's being placed in District one. It's not not living in District one.
I went for solidarity. It's not my bag to talk about what should happen one way or the other. I would like to say, though, that it was interesting.
It was confirmed when I brought up in the meeting that it seemed like what I was understanding from the data that there are energy inefficiency issues happening in District one that contributed to the battery being placed in that district.
And I think that we as a city need to look into that more and provide that district with what it needs to be able to to meet that.
The officials from Huntsville utilities mentioned about there being energy efficient efficiency programs.
And when I asked about it, when I followed up with that and asked, you know, where is the data for transparency?
I'd like to see how many, you know, how many times it's been applied for and how many times that successfully happened.
I there's just no data there. So, you know, there's no way to confirm that one way or the other how well that's working.
I would also like to bring up I've been going through some efforts to raise bus fare for people coming out of the jail.
Right. I've been going on about this for some time. Several meetings now.
Our sheriff's department's very open to it. I would really appreciate it if our city council and Mayor Tommy Battle. It may have to come from you.
So thank you. Look forward to an email from me.
Jerry Cox is I don't see Jerry here is Jerry.
He was our last signed up to be our last speaker. So that we have no more speakers.
Is there any other business before the council? We are adjourned at six forty eight.
Thank you all for joining us. Yes, ma'am.